- Hi everyone, welcome to
our Homeroom livestream.
Sal here, from Khan Academy.
Before we get into our
guest, who is me today,
(chuckling)
it's just gonna be an ask
me anything type of thing.
So actually start putting
your questions on Facebook
and YouTube and we have team members
who will Surface them to me,
and you can ask literally about anything.
I will give my standard
announcement, reminder,
that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization.
We're funded through
philanthropic donations.
Special shout-out to several corporations
that have stepped up,
especially as our costs
went up due to COVID.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, and Novartis.
But even with that support,
we were already running
into deficit pre-COVID crisis,
and that deficit has accelerated
because of our increased costs,
as our server load has gone up,
and we're trying to do more
programs, more content.
First, thanks for those
who have stepped up,
especially those corporations.
Thank you for all of you who have donated.
But if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
We only exist because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So with that said, I am eager
to answer your questions about anything.
And let's see what
questions are coming in.
I'll just wait around a little bit.
I will say, while we're waiting
for some questions to come in,
yesterday's conversation
with David Sinclair,
as y'all know I have been
following David for many years,
and I think I made him feel
a little awkward when I,
'cause obviously he's
talked about life extension,
and he's, he looks eerily young.
But when he told me that
getting winded helps you
with your health, I went for
an extra fast run this morning
on an empty stomach,
'cause he also said that.
Once again, if you're a growing
kid, eat your regular meals,
don't listen to anything from me.
Even if you're a fully grown person,
don't take any health, nutrition,
or medical advice from me.
The intermittent fasting does seem to,
at least in my head, kinda work.
So that was an interesting take-away.
It was very tangible life advice
that we got from David yesterday.
So I am eager to get
more questions, and I am.
Am I in the right doc?
I am not seeing any
questions here showing up.
Or maybe people are just, you know,
maybe we've answered everyone's questions.
That's an interesting thing to ponder,
that there's no questions left.
Let's see, yeah, I'm in the
doc, I don't see any questions.
Are you there?
There are people who are on the same,
we're on the same doc with
some of our team members.
Philippe, am I in the right doc?
I just typed in it, 'cause I
don't see anything coming up.
Oh, there we go, we got
some questions coming up.
So from Facebook, Luis Vega says,
"Can Khan Academy reduce
the risk of infection
to our children around the world?"
Well Luis, that was quite
a question that we got
to start our AMA here.
So it depends on what
layer you're talking about.
Obviously I don't think
Khan Academy is going
to prevent the infection, but if,
in many parts of the world
school closures are continuing
or there's some type of hybrid learning
where kids are going to have
to learn from home online,
and that's obviously a place
where Khan Academy can keep,
help keep the learning happening
while there are school closures because,
and the school closures
are there, obviously,
to keep families and keep
everyone from getting sick.
So I think that's Khan
Academy's primary role here,
as we have a very real, legitimate role
during these school closures.
We've talked about it before,
our traffic has gone up
almost by a factor of three.
When schools are open,
I suspect it's going
to only accelerate as we
get back into school season.
And then I guess there's another layer of,
an education layer that we play,
whether it's this type of conversation,
bringing guests on who
can speak to the virus.
We had Bill Gates on several months ago.
We're actually going to
have several other experts
on health and vaccination
in the coming weeks.
So that's another role we can play,
and obviously we can teach
people about biology,
about exponential growth, and
that can hopefully inform.
But I think our biggest
role in the immediate now
is how do we keep people learning.
How do we support students,
parents, and teachers
during these very hard times for schools
because of what's going on?
So from Facebook, Sadiya Ija says,
"Tips to make online
teaching more interesting."
So great question, and I
think there's two types
of online teaching, at least two,
maybe there's more than two.
There's what I would call
asynchronous online teaching
and then there's
synchronous online teaching.
Asynchronous online teaching
is, for the most part,
what Khan Academy does.
Students can go at
their own time and pace.
They can get as much
practice, they get feedback,
there's game mechanics for them.
And then if they need supports,
there's hints, and there's videos.
And if you were thinking
about these videos,
which are asynchronous,
I'm obviously not giving the lesson
at the exact moment that a
student is watching the lesson,
there I think it's very important
for whoever is the content creator
to feel genuinely passionate
about what they are talking about,
to have a deep, not just interest in it,
but a deep understanding of it.
Because I think if those
two things aren't true
when you're giving the lesson,
then I think as human beings,
we're very sensitive to tone.
And we know that hey this
person isn't excited about it,
why should I be excited about it?
I would say another thing,
I'm not saying you cannot
make a great piece of content
if it's scripted, but once
again, human beings, students,
we're very sensitive to tone.
And you usually can tell the difference
if someone is reading a script
versus if someone is actually
speaking from their mind.
And when you speak from your mind,
you might say a few more ums,
you might pause or stutter a little bit,
but I actually think it's a good trade off
because people know you're a human being,
and you are just trying
to make transparent the thought process.
So I definitely try to do
that when I make my videos.
Many of y'all know I do them somewhat,
you know I look at what the standards are,
what I need to cover, sometimes
I'll prepare some visuals,
or some graphics, or some
charts, some example problems,
but when I do it, I'm there,
I'm there in real time,
in the same head space as the student
while I'm recording the video.
If you're doing a
synchronous online lesson,
so let's say you're doing
it over Zoom, or Hangouts,
or something, like some
type of video conferencing,
there I think, well actually
some of the same things apply
where you know, try to
have interest in it,
try to have passion for it.
I actually would say this would also apply
in a physical classroom.
But I think it's that much more important
if you're on something like
Zoom or video conferencing
to keep it as interactive as possible.
So it should not be the teacher, or you,
just lecturing to
students for half an hour,
or for 30 minutes,
or for however long that
video conference session is.
The more it can be like hey,
here's an interesting idea,
maybe a couple of minutes
of background or context,
and say okay, now I want all of y'all
to figure out something,
whatever subject it is.
And obviously in some of
these video conferencing tools
you can put kids into breakouts.
I think that is actually
the best thing to do
for the synchronous, 'cause
you're really leveraging
the fact that live human
beings are connecting,
at least virtually, in the moment.
So if I was running a
Zoom session, I would say,
well if I were doing both,
if I were a teacher who's
having to keep kids learning
while COVID's going on and
schools are physically closed,
I would say use Khan Academy,
depending on your age,
some place between 30 and 60 minutes a day
to make sure that you get
all of your core skills
and content, that that,
you keep developing that,
and that several times a week,
maybe three times a week,
we'll get on video
conference for 45 minutes.
And the way that I would
run those video conferences
is at least two of them a week,
I would have the students,
I would give them some context,
but then I would give them a
challenging series of problems,
and maybe ones that would be challenging
for different levels of students,
and then I would ask the
students to go into breakouts
and in small groups,
try to work through it.
Or maybe first, I would
say hey everyone try
to do it themselves,
come up with a solution,
and then put them into breakouts
and try to explain their
solutions to each other,
and then come back,
and then talk about it.
If I'm in a humanities class,
I would put some interesting
issue on the table,
as to you are Julius Caesar,
you crossed the Rubicon,
and then let the kids vote,
then let them go into breakouts,
let them debate with each other,
in kind of Julius Caesar's head
as to whether they should
cross the Rubicon or not.
And then come back, and
then people kind of debrief.
I think that type of
interaction will keep it
as human as possible in this online world.
And frankly, everything
I just said about online,
I think is also, in a lot of ways,
optimal for the physical world as well.
From Facebook, Salina Chang says,
"Sal, when and how do you
structure your daily schedule?"
There's two different things
that Salina might be referring to.
She might be referring to
we have issued a daily,
right when COVID hit,
that was back in March,
feels like a lifetime ago,
we issued, we said look,
parents are gonna need help
structuring their days.
Right now people are saying
here's a bunch of links,
make use of it, and we
said parents need help
knowing how to structure
their student's day
so that they can cover the material,
have time for breaks, for
play, for lunch, whatever else.
So we published daily schedules.
The way that was created was we,
myself and several team members,
we said okay, let's put
all of this together.
Like what are the
must-haves in a school day,
or in a homeschooling day, or
on a quarantine-schooling day?
How do you make sure
you have enough breaks?
How do you make sure that
you have enough free time,
time outside, but also
that you're covering
all your key subjects?
And then we've been
refining that ever since,
based on feedback from
parents, and students,
and teachers, and education
researchers around the world.
If Salina is asking how
do I schedule my day,
there's a couple things.
So I've said multiple
times on this livestream,
I like to start with
some wins, so I always,
I would say 90% of days,
I will get out of bed,
and I will do a meditation
for 20 to 30, sometimes 40 minutes.
Then I try to do some physical exercise,
which I try to actually do a
couple of handstand pushups,
then I go running as fast
as I can for about a mile.
Then I make my bed, and
sometimes, well I make my bed.
Then I kinda do my classic brush
your teeth, et cetera stuff
and then I'm into my day.
And my ideal day is that my
mornings is when I'm fresh,
where my brain can handle
the most cognitive load,
and so that's when I try
to do content creation,
'cause content creation does
take a lot of cognitive load.
It's one thing to do a math problem,
or to explain some concept
in physics or the humanities,
it's another thing to do it
while you're speaking out loud,
and being recorded, and
writing on a screen.
So I try to make sure that my
brain is very fresh for that.
And then my middle of the day,
I kind of have a lot of meetings.
Khan Academy, we have
over 200 folks, engineers,
product designers, product
managers, fundraising.
Relative to where it started,
it's a reasonably
complex organization now.
And so wherever I can help support folks
do the important work they're doing,
that's kinda my middle of the day.
I'm also talking a lot to,
right before this I got
off the phone with a philanthropist,
explaining how we're running at a deficit
and that we need their support.
In the middle of the day I do.
Obviously I do the press
whenever they need me,
because that just helps build awareness
that we have this tool out there.
Yesterday I had to wake
up at 5:00 in the morning
for Fox Business, 'cause
it was on the East Coast,
so doing what it takes to spread the word.
But in my ideal day, I would
then, by the afternoon,
hopefully I'm just trying to
finish up all my odds and ends.
And I just got a message
that I have something
on the top of my head.
It does look like I do,
and I couldn't see it
'cause it was just this
little, oh yeah, there you go.
Just a, it's a little white
piece of paper or something.
Let's see, from Facebook,
Saraj Dodse says,
"Is data science really a
course for a top-notch job?"
I would say yeah, yeah,
data science is a really
good skill to have,
I would say in almost any field you go to.
Data science is funny.
I spoke at the, I forgot
what they call it,
it's like in the National
Actuarial Society.
And for those of you who
don't know what an actuary is,
an actuary, and the job of an
actuary has existed for many,
at least decades, maybe even a century,
frankly as long as things like insurance
have existed actually, so
that's probably many centuries.
But they are the folks
who look at the data
of like what's the probability
that a father of three
who's 43 years old, who
drives a Honda Accord,
will get into a car accident,
and then how much would that
car accident cost on average,
and then based on that, what
should their car insurance be
so that it's profitable for the insurance,
but also something that is reasonable
for the father of three, which
I've just described myself.
So that job is inherently data science.
They're looking at large data sets,
and coming up with insights of it
in order to make kind
of business decisions.
Statistics, statisticians, actuaries
have always been doing data science.
Now with this notion of big data,
and you can imagine, even at Khan Academy,
we have tens of millions
of people doing exercises.
Can we use that data in
ways that is constructive?
And we're very careful.
We would never wanna use the
data, we're a non-profit,
we would never wanna use it in shady ways.
But can we use it in ways
that can improve the learning,
can do better personalization?
Can we learn insights that
maybe certain types of concepts
are easier to learn for
certain types of students
in one way versus another way?
And so it's kind of taking
that same lens of statistics,
and what actuaries do, but
with a little bit of coding
and computer programming to be able
to query these large data sets
and know how to structure
these large data sets,
and how to actually come
with real insights from them.
And that's going on
in pretty much every
industry in the world.
So yes, simple answer
is, if it interests you,
I think it's a great thing.
And I think even if you don't
wanna become a data scientist,
I think it's really valuable
to become reasonably familiar
with it because in
pretty much any function,
you're going to be asking
these types of questions.
And maybe there's an analytics
or a data science group
that does some of the work,
but you need to be informed
in order to know how to structure
the questions correctly,
or to know what that information
is telling you or not telling you.
So yeah, it's a good, good career
if it's of interest to you.
So from Facebook, Kunza Thireek says,
"How do deal with ADHD children these days
for online classes, are
there any tips for them?"
So Kunza, I'm not an expert.
I'm definitely not the,
take everything I say
with a super grain of salt.
What we've told all
parents, and I think this,
my gut sense, my intuitive sense,
is that this might be valuable
for students with ADHD is
start simple and build a habit.
So let's say math, or school in general.
If your school, if your
child's school is closed,
and you're doing this
quarantine schooling,
you don't have to replicate
all of school, all at once.
That'll be overwhelming for you,
that'll be overwhelming for your child.
What I would say is do
even 20 minutes a day.
If attention span is an
issue, a 15 minute session,
a 10 minute session, sit next to them,
and I don't know how old
they are, but work through.
If they're able to do 15
minutes a day on Khan Academy,
maybe first thing in the morning,
and then create that habit,
then they're going to progress.
And then if that feels
like that's firm footing,
that habit, then you could
then build on top of that.
So that's my best advice is to start small
and really focus on building habits
versus trying to boil
the ocean all at once.
So from Facebook, John Bernard Horn says,
"Sal, how can we all
help people steer clear
of questionable conspiracy theories,
specifically regards to COVID, SARS2."
I mean I think the best way to steer clear
of conspiracy theories are,
is to just be well-informed about things,
have good critical-thinking skills,
and you know, talk to people
you might not agree with,
get their points of view.
I will say that before Khan Academy,
and this Khan Academy experience,
you see, you read a lot about
what goes on in the world,
and it is sometimes tempting,
and this was even before social media
where your friend says well I'm not sure
if that's what really happened,
I think that person did it
so that this would happen
because they benefited from it.
One thing is that in my
Khan Academy experience,
I've had the luxury of
meeting some of these actors,
some of these world leaders,
or some of these CEOs,
or some of these people
with a lot of resources,
and I have to say when
you kind of meet them,
and they're not, they don't have to be on,
and they're just kind
of being human beings,
I've become much more skeptical
of conspiracy theories
because I realize that most
people are just like trying
to make it through the day.
You might think that,
and maybe what I'm about to say is scary,
that some of these intelligence
agencies and this and that,
that they have these like magical pieces
of information and all that,
but they're running off of,
sometimes they find out
about stuff from the news.
I've become even more skeptical
of conspiracy theories.
What I say is always use
critical thinking skills.
And look, I would say most of the time,
your critical thinking
skills will tell you
that the conspiracy theories
are not likely true,
but every now and then,
maybe the mainstream view isn't true.
But that's where your
critical thinking skills
are going to be really, really valuable,
because yeah, I think it
is always interesting.
I read a lot of books, and
I like these plot twists
where there's like a surprise,
like oh you thought it was
this, but it's actually that,
and you say oh well of course,
party B was the beneficiary,
so even though they looked
like the good guy, maybe they aren't.
That's interesting, you have to,
and maybe our human brain
naturally does that type of thing.
But you know, in some cases,
if you look at historical wars,
history has unearthed that sometimes
it was a false flag attack or whatever.
Now with COVID and SARS and all that,
I see zero evidence, personally,
to think that it's anything
but what we are being told it is.
It's a zoonotic virus, or at least COVID,
through mutations and viruses,
especially RNA viruses mutate a lot,
and so mutated so that it
can survive in a human host.
It happens to have the
properties that make it,
it's not so lethal, and
in the early stages,
and for many people, they're asymptomatic,
and so that's what allows it to spread,
but then for certain
people it is scary enough
and bad enough and lethal enough
that we all have to be very
conscientious about it,
not scared, but very thoughtful
about how we make sure
it doesn't spread and how
we don't expose people.
Every now and then, through
these random mutations,
unfortunately it looks like
something like this shows up.
But who knows, but I see
no reason for anyone,
I would just say equip yourself
with critical thinking skills,
don't believe everything
you see on social media.
I have family members who forward me
all sorts of stuff on social media.
And if you just do a simple web search,
like four out of the five
things you can outright
just say they're false statements,
like you can just see
that they make no sense.
So I would encourage you
to do your own research
and talk to opposing viewpoints.
So from Outdoor B Channel on YouTube,
"Sal sir, what are you plans
for the future of Khan Academy?"
That is a big question Outdoor B.
So many of y'all know our
mission as a not-for-profit
is free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
There's three parts of that vision.
One is that a learner
anywhere in the world
should have access to world-class learning
as early as pre-K, all the
way through elementary,
middle, high school, and college,
across subjects and grades,
in all of the world's major languages.
So just that's a big statement,
and we're on that journey.
The second pillar is they should be able
to learn that material in an engaging way
that's personalized to their needs,
and it should not be
bound by time and space.
I've talked a lot about mastery learning,
and that one of the main issues
is that kids keep moving ahead,
but they accumulate a gap.
They get an 80% on one
test, a 70% on another test,
and then all of a sudden
they're in algebra class
and nothing makes sense
because they didn't learn
decimals well in fifth grade,
or negative numbers well in sixth grade.
And so mastery learning,
personalization helps address that.
And then the third pillar
of Khan Academy is that
I hope that one day Khan
Academy can be used as evidence
of what you have mastered,
you could almost view it as
something of a credential.
We had Jim Nondorf as a
guest on this livestream,
the Head of Admissions
from University of Chicago,
and he said he would
love students to submit
what they've mastered on Khan Academy
as evidence of not only their
academic mastery of content,
but also to show the admissions officers
that they have real determination
and agency over their learning,
and they really can learn something
at their own time and pace.
So there's that whole credentialing piece
that I also hope is the
future of Khan Academy.
And I hope, if we go five,
10, 20 years in the future,
Khan Academy is serving,
we have 107 million
registered users today,
I'm hoping that we're
serving billions of learners,
across subjects and grades,
in all of the world's major languages,
and they can point to Khan
Academy as a major reason
why they have become empowered
people in the world who,
for the most part, don't
believe in conspiracy theories.
(chuckling)
From YouTube, Aidan
Hadamee Kermansha asks,
"How would you revolutionize
studying and school criteria?"
If I'm understanding
this question correctly,
what I would focus on, you know right now,
traditional schools, you kinda sit,
you kinda go through a
process, you take a test,
and whatever score you get on
the test, that is what it is.
I mean if it's bad enough, you might fail,
but then you kind of
move onto the next thing.
That's kind of a time-based
credentialing model.
I'm a proponent, and I've advocated,
and I continue to advocate,
and it goes into the last question,
of what I would call a
competency-based model
where there's some way,
maybe an assessment,
could be a paper-based
assessment, online assessment,
in-person assessment, or some combination,
it could be a practical assessment
where you have to do something,
where if you can do it,
you get a certain cut score,
you get a certain score,
you know your algebra, you know chemistry,
you know data science,
whatever it might be.
And then you have the decision
of the path of how to get there.
You can do it at your own time and pace.
You can use Khan Academy, maybe
Khan Academy in conjunction
with a MOOC, it could
be in class experience,
it could be using a textbook,
it could be your best friend tutoring you.
What matters is that you
get to that endpoint.
As soon as you get to that
competency-based model,
then a lot of things change.
One, I think the credentials
become more powerful
because people know that
you learned the material.
But then I think it
clarifies what's the role
of the learning experience.
How do you make sure that you're getting
to that very well-defined
outcome that matters?
So that would be, I
would say, the main one.
I would say there's other structures.
Learning should not be
bound by time or space.
We've talked about this for many years,
and obviously COVID is
making this a necessity,
learning should not be
bound by time and space.
Students should be able to
learn at their own time,
in a personalized way.
Teachers should be empowered with data
so they can know what interventions
are gonna be most valuable
for their students.
Class time, or in-person, human time,
whether it's in a classroom,
or whether it's on video conferencing,
should be as interactive
and as active as possible.
It should not just be someone
lecturing or just talking.
It should be students working
together on interesting things
and pushing each other, and
answering each other's questions
and being able to talk to each other,
versus you know kind of sit there silently
and not saying anything.
They should either be doing
problems on their own,
or working with others and collaborating,
including the teacher.
From Facebook, Eunice Bay, or Beg, Bay,
"Name one teacher who
had an impact on you.
I am very curious."
From Kashmir, okay, that's great.
From Kashmir, what is it,
it's like middle of the night
in Kashmir right now.
So Eunice, I can name many, many teachers.
I remember, I mean if
you go all the way back,
Miss Roberts in kindergarten,
Miss Lunda in first grade,
Miss Darby in second grade, and you know,
they were really important
because you're young,
but they were the first people
that I think I got positive feedback.
I remember, they kind of said,
"Hey Sal, I'm impressed
how you're doing this."
It might have been like
how I colored something.
The fact that I remember it
shows that it really helped
with kind of my self esteem.
And then as you get into kind
of third and fourth grade,
there was Miss Krauss and Miss Rucell,
and this was kind of an enrichment program
where I remember the
first time that I went,
and this was in a standard public school,
Metairie, Louisiana, which
is not a wealthy part
of the country, for sure,
and Louisiana is not a wealthy state,
but I remember the first time
I went into this enrichment,
and Miss, I think it
was Miss Rucell asked,
"So Sal, what are you interested in?"
And I was like seven or eight years old,
and that was the first
time that kind of an adult
had genuinely, authentically said,
"What are you really interested in?"
And when I said that I
really liked puzzles,
and I really liked art and drawing,
her response was, "Then we
will do puzzles and drawing,"
and that blew me away.
Like she asked me, I told her,
and then I'm just going
to get to do more of that.
I remember in second, third,
fourth grade, I would kinda,
it was this enrichment
program where I got to play,
one I'd be doing these
deductive reasoning puzzles,
then I'd get to draw some days,
then I would get to play
chess or another game,
and I thought I was getting
away with something.
But in hindsight, sometimes
we would study art
or famous artists, or try
to make art in their style,
and this was second grade,
third grade, fourth grade,
in hindsight that's some of
my best learning I ever had.
Some of the best learning happens
when it doesn't even feel
like school, so to speak,
it feels like you're doing
what you have a passion for,
but it's very constructive, and
you're getting better at it.
It was really powerful to
have kind of an adult there
to encourage that type.
And then if you get into
fifth grade, Miss Ellis,
I remember she ran her
American history course
kind of like a college seminar.
She would be at the front, she
would always be eating fruit,
and she would be like peeling
it, I have just this memory,
I was a fifth grader, she
would be peeling these oranges.
She was very like almost
what you would imagine as very elegant,
kind of elderly woman at the time,
seemed elderly, I mean
I'm probably her age now.
And she would just ask us these questions,
like so we just read that
president so-and-so did this,
but would you have done that,
and she would make us answer,
you know as fifth graders,
no I think Roosevelt did the wrong thing,
we didn't have to expand the government,
say no but that was important,
it's what brought us
out of the Depression,
otherwise we would have had unemployed.
And to be in a fifth grade class,
to have those types of
conversations, as you can tell,
I remembered it, and it impacted me.
And then as you go into middle school,
I remember Miss North,
actually very similar
to Miss Rucell in how she ran her classes,
and actually very similar to Miss Ellis.
I still remember one of her
classes, it was an English class
but we spent the whole
hour talking about reality.
Like what is real, and
how do you know it's real?
That's mind blowing, it's still
mind-blowing conversation.
And then as you go into high school,
there was Mister Hernandez,
who I was very close to,
he was kind of a sponsor
for our math team,
for our academic games team,
which I was stereotypically
very involved in,
probably not a surprise to y'all,
but he was someone who really acted
as a mentor, who pushed me.
When I wanted to, when I was thinking
about applying to college,
he encouraged me to think
very big, and to think,
you know, he's like Sal, you
could, don't put blinders on,
don't just try to do what
other people are doing,
you can, you should think
big about your future.
And also Miss Kennedy who
was our journalism teacher,
and I was the art editor
of our school newspaper.
Once again, just another,
I think if there's a common theme here,
these are adults who are
really amazing teachers
who I felt didn't just see me
as another face in the class,
they got to know me, they
took the time to advise me,
they treated me as, you
know they didn't talk down,
they treated me as, I
wouldn't say an equal,
but someone, a mentor-mentee
type relationship,
which really sticks with you.
And actually I'd be remiss,
when I was in high school,
I started taking classes at
the University of New Orleans
when I was about 14 or 15,
I was taking these fancy math classes.
I started taking multi-variable
and partial-differential
equations and all this kinda stuff
and there was a teacher,
he was actually my
partial-differential equations teacher
at University of New Orleans,
his name was Doctor Santania.
I think there was some work that we needed
to do on a computer, and when
he found out that my family,
we had like no money, my mom was a cashier
at a convenience store,
making minimum wage,
and then we later had a
failing convenience store,
and we had no computer for sure,
he kinda of said look,
you've kinda got a knack
for this type of stuff, you
should have access to a computer
and so he kinda pulled
all sorts of strings
for me to have access,
the same access the engineering students
at the university had to the computers.
And that was the first time that I got
to really program computers
and realize how much I enjoyed it,
and that obviously led
to me becoming a computer
science and math major.
And I'm sure I'm missing
a lot of teachers,
but those are the ones.
You asked the question,
so I gave you a very,
as thorough of an answer
as I could for that.
I just noticed that I'm all out time.
These were good questions.
We started slow on the questions,
but it definitely picked up,
and now there's a ton of questions.
I think next time if we start slow,
I'll just get back to
some of these questions
that I have right here.
But I really appreciate all the questions.
And tomorrow, we're going
to have Jacquelline Fuller,
who is the president of Google.org,
which is the arm of Google
that is philanthropic
and doing what it can.
And I would say Google generally is trying
to do what it can to,
I guess organize the world's
information or knowledge.
But Google.org is very
much interested in things
in kind of the not-for-profit
philanthropic sector,
and actually they've
been big funders of ours.
I'm eager to talk to Jacquelline,
who I consider a good friend,
on what's on their plate because of COVID
and everything else in the world,
and how we can collectively
help address those issues.
So I look forward to seeing
all of y'all tomorrow.
(electronic music)